so I learned a lot about Whitney that I
didn't know while watching the movie
um when you were prepping for the role
what were some of the things that
actually surprised you that perhaps you
didn't know I can't say it totally
surprised me but just seeing the weight
I was able to relate but obviously not
on a scale that she has experienced
I was able to to pay attention to the
weight that she carried and the
responsibility that she had to just
about everybody around her like she was
the captain she was the leader and you
know that I I that took a toll I feel on
her and it was it was a lot of weight to
carry but I think she did it as
gracefully as possible so that was
pretty cool to see also I think I
learned too she's she's Whitney was
always going to do things her way
and I think that there's something about
about that uh autonomy that I felt like
she had where it was she she
although they had ideas for her career
she I feel stayed true and authentic to
who she was she stayed true and
authentic to who she wanted to marry and
you know she did things on her own terms
her story is a little bit for me when I
was watching uh obviously it's
heartbreaking that she uh with
everything that happened but I also
wonder and and
maybe if she'd been born a little closer
to today if her
self-destructive behavior and maybe drug
use was hiding
who she wanted or who she was if I'm not
sure if I'm making that any you know if
I'm making that uh make sense but do you
sort of agree with what I'm saying like
maybe
um some of that was masking who she was
you know I like to focus on the
celebration of of of of what she was
able to accomplish and focus on you know
putting my all into the film which I'm
really excited for y'all to see me play
and portray
um one of the closest people ever to her
who is Robin and you know we all know
how the story ends and it's I don't like
to really do the Shoulda Coulda woulda's
because you know everything happens when
it's supposed to and how I believe so I
try not to focus on that too much and
just focus on the idea of how much
everybody is going to love this film and
yes we tell the truth but it's also just
a beautiful celebration of her life and
her Legacy I do believe
um and obviously I'm aware that we live
in a different time where you're not
able to fully be you weren't able to
fully be who you were especially
especially in the industry as we are
today so I do wish things were a bit
more acceptable and you know
yeah those are my feelings towards that
totally when you were looking at the
shooting schedule I'm sure there was a
day or two on the shoot that you're like
either super nervous to do or super
excited
um what was that on the shooting
schedule
the the challenging seems for me to film
were the breakup scenes with her and
Robin
and my heart kind of broke for Robin
because I know the depth of love that
she had for her Robin and I are both
Sagittariuses I'm not sure if you're in
a Zodiacs or not zodiacs
um but we love really really deeply and
loyal to a fault and you know it kind of
crushed me to film those to film those
scenes because
you know they start on such a high with
this love and it's kind of like it's a
rejection and it's like it's a
disappointment in there and and that was
really tough like my heart was breaking
actually having to film that
so that was a challenging moment
um on that note I already have to stop
I'm just gonna say like I said at the
beginning congrats good luck with your
speed dating and I hope the film is a
huge hit for you